10. a record number of guns were found  at tsa checkpoints last year even as  travel remained below pre-pandemic  levels we're talking nearly 6 000  firearms 86 of them were loaded now this  is all coming from a tsa report which  shows atlanta's heartbeat  hartsfield-jackson took the number one  spot with dallas houston phoenix and  nashville rounding out the top five  what's causing it i don't know exactly  but generally i think our weapons  carriage detections reflect just more  people carrying weapons in the country  well the penalty is costly in case you  were wondering there's a nearly 14  thousand dollar fine in addition to  whatever charges local law enforcement  brings